قاعده بوكا جونيورز ترسم وشمالي رونالدو
نجم المنتخب في فريقه جيرات بيكي وكلاب
بيتبول تقتل نجمه زامبيا السابق هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
في الوقت الذي تشهد فيه الشعبيه ميسي
التزودا كبيرا في الارجنتين اخترت قائدته
بوكا جونيورز رسم وشم لرونالدو على ساقها
اليسرى بدلا من رسم الذي قاد المنتخب
بلادها للفوز بكاس العالم يعمل قاده تخفي
الوشمه تحت جوربها لكنها كشف في مباراتها
الاخيره ولكم ان تتخيلوا كيف كانت تعليقات
رواد السوشيال ميديا في الارجنتين على هذه
الصور
تفاجا المشجعون في اسبانيا وعلى مواقع
التواصل بلاعب متخفن ضمن فريق كيكي الذي
خاض مباراه في بطوله استعراضيه تضم لاعبين
السابقين ومؤثرين على السوشيال ميديا نجم
برشلونه السابق اعلن عبر حساب على تويتر
بان اللاعب المتخفي هو نجم في الدوري
الاسباني لكن لا يمكن الكشف عن هويته بسبب
عقده الاحترافي وكان اللاعب المجهول قد
ارتدي قناعا يشبه قناع المصارعه المكسيكي
لوتشا ليبر كما غلط
وبعد انسحابي دون سبب المحدد من بطوله
استراليا المفتوحه اعلنت نجمه التنس نام
اوساكا عبر حسابي على الانستغرام بانها
حامل ولا تشارك في اولى بطولات للجراند
سلام وكانت اوساكا قد اختفت على الانظار
في الفتره الاخيره خاصه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ما اثر قلق القائم على البطوله
ومن المتوقع ان تغيب اللاعب اليابانيه عن
باقي منافسات الموسم الحالي بعد هذا
الاعلان
في خبرنا الاخير توفي نجم منتخب زامبيا
السابق بعد هجوم كلابه عليه في حديقه
منزله الواقع في جنوب افريقيا
حتى الموت زوجه مولانا كانت في المنزل
وسمعت صوت الكلاب والتي هي من نوع بيتبول
لكنها لم تتحقق من الامر كون المنزل يقع
في شارع المزدحم ونباعها هو شيء طبيعي
ومتكرر خلال اليوم لكن ما هو سبب الذي دفع
هذه الكلاب الشرسه لمهاجمه صاحبها وقتله